country music legend Lee Greenwood knows
a little bit about uh what it's like to
be pro-american and patriotic Lee great
to see you twice in like a week yeah
thank you I mean this is great to see
you thanks for being in the angle right
here they operate to wonder Awards I'm
dressed up for the Patriot Awards I love
it you again everyone looks so handsome
and beautiful all right what do you do
do you think what do we do to turn this
around with young people amplifying bin
Laden's propagandistic hateful remarks
well I got an answer for you it's family
Goden country I mean if you believe in
that and of course I have something
special for you what I have a God Bless
the USA Bible and in it is the
Constitution and Declaration of
Independence the Pledge of Allegiance
and the Bill of Rights and I've signed
it for you and I want you to have it as
my gift the thing is is if we just
believe in America like we've never
believed in her she stands for freedom
for the world and you know when you talk
about the word Patriot uh in the
dictionary it says love devotion and and
a sense of Attraction for your country
and satisfaction so you know there's
people who do vol unism and for
sacrifice and it's all about sacrificing
for our country now well when you think
about it freedom I think it was Dwight
Eisenhower said it's not it doesn't
happen by chance it happens by choice a
choice that Americans make every day
that you you want to live in Freedom and
how how do you live in Freedom you have
to step up and defend Freedom absolutely
we're generation from losing the
Republic it takes the young kids we need
to make sure that our children
understand what the sacrifice is for the
freedom that we enjoy so Lee at the
opery house all the greats have
performed I mean have you you've
performed at the yeah almost once a
month how many times oh um I I came here
in 1979 so probably at least three or
four times a year since then four in
1979 come on I don't believe that I
don't believe that all right so you feel
the presence of of Music greatness when
you're when you're at the Opera at the
opera house when you think about talent
and real talent and how it's just it's
evolved over time different different
types of sounds and so forth who was
your favorite of favorites in the
country music genre um I guess Johnny
Cash I was gonna say it's got to be
Johnny Cash of course you know the man
in Black here we are one time he only
perform one time at the oper in 1954
that was it for I worked with them
several times as well you know and talk
about that about my touring schedule you
know I I said the other day and I know
Fox reported it might be my last year to
tour uh that's nonsense better not be
we'll we're tour like crazy next year
thanks to aec our new agency here in
Nashville Fant of course be ready for
Donald Trump when he runs 25 o well I
heard you saying proud to be an American
last week or a week before last I was
balling when you were perform I mean I I
get so emotional I just I just get
emotional when I hear that song it
reminds me of Reagan reminds me of the
80s which were awesome and I worked with
all of them I know and you work for all
of them and I was work a young uh Speech
writer in the White House you were four
years old ex thank you very much Le
great to see you thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else